que c'est toute la bataille menée depuis
le 19e siècle
qui se trouve ainsi résumé la bataille
pour le temps de vivre la conquête du
temps de vie mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que la vie qu'est-ce que c'était que la
vie pour un prolétaire au milieu du 19e
siècle c'était à 7 ou 8 ans le travail
pour le compte des autres c'était le
travail jusqu'à la mort et sans repos il
n'y avait pas de retraite à la fin de la
vie il n'y avait pas d'arrêt de vacances
ou de congés payés en cours d'année il
n'y avait pas de week-end il n'y avait
pas de journée de repos peut-être
parfois le dimanche matin pour la messe
la retraite est entendu que lorsque la
retraite a été fixée à 65 ans la moyenne
de vie des travailleurs était de 55
c'est comme ça que les choses se sont
faites en arrachant à la société
dirigeante les concessions qu'elles
refusaient